[Música]
por esta época pero hace aproximadamente
tres años comenzaban a darse a conocer
los primeros casos de contagios de
covid-19 en la ciudad de buján en China
al día de hoy la pandemia de acuerdo con
el conteo de la universidad John Hopkins
reporta que la pandemia de Kobe 19 ha
dejado más de 6 millones 640.000
personas fallecidas los casos
oficialmente reportados superan los 645
millones 576.000
tres años después y ante un aparente
regreso de la normalidad china que es el
país de origen de la pandemia sigue con
una política muy estricta de covid cero
o cero covid que ha llevado a
manifestaciones de rechazo por parte de
los ciudadanos que están Ya cansados de
los confinamientos las restricciones los
cierres y también la persecución por
parte de las autoridades que ahora pues
también han comenzado a dar algún tipo
de flexibilización con algunas de las
políticas que han adoptado pero algo de
china en esta pandemia que el resto del
mundo tal vez parece que no ve porque
los casos de Kobe 19 están en aumento en
algunos países del mundo en nuestra
región por ejemplo países como Perú
chile Argentina y Colombia llevan un
poco más de tres semanas con aumento
sostenido de casos de contagio de
covid-19 incluso han reportado algunas
víctimas mortales si bien el Coby 19
nunca se fue nos preguntamos está de
regreso el Coby 19 A qué nos estamos
exponiendo en este momento tenía razón
china en mantener sus restricciones y su
política de cero covid qué saben los
chinos que nosotros no sabemos pues lo
vamos a analizar hoy en el debate de
France 24 y para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Daniel López Acuña
exdirector de acción sanitaria en
situación de crisis de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud y también está con
nosotros Jaime Ordóñez él es php en
epidemiología ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales ustedes ya las
conocen estamos en Twitter en Facebook y
en instagram nos encuentran como arroba
el debate_f24 arroba santilogo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta para que
dejen sus comentarios ustedes ya lo
saben numeral el debate f24 todo junto
todo pegado y no olviden también que
todos los contenidos de este programa
están disponibles también en diferentes
plataformas de podcast nos encuentran en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn
pues le doy entonces la bienvenida a
Daniel López para comenzar a hacer la
ronda de preguntas y conocer posiciones
sobre lo que estamos analizando el día
de hoy Daniel Bienvenido al programa
Gracias por estar con nosotros y era
esperado este tipo de repunte de Casos
de la pandemia de covid 19 Es parte
normal del ciclo de las pandemias o algo
hicimos mal que están volviendo a ver
casos en diferentes países del mundo
Bueno lo primero es señalar que quienes
hayan preconizado la idea de que la
pandemia había terminado estaba en un
error graso la pandemia no ha terminado
el virus está circulando está haciendo
transmitido es un virus que tiene muchas
mucha tendencia a las mutaciones y a
producir variantes peligrosas y
amenazantes en términos de severidad o
de riesgo de muerte y en la medida en
que bajemos la guardia tanto de medidas
de protección como de medidas
específicas de tipo farmacológico como
es la vacunación vamos a tener
inevitablemente repuntes de la
enfermedad y vamos a tener lo que
estamos observando especialmente en
temporadas otoño invernales en el
hemisferio norte que es un
recrudecimiento de la enfermedad sumada
a la al incremento de otras enfermedades
respiratorias agudas como la gripe
estacional o el virus respiratorio
sincicial
Cuál es la opinión de Jaime Ordóñez
nuestro siguiente invitado aquí en el
debate de France 24 Jaime bienvenido
también a qué se debe este repunte de
Caso Será algo esperado es algo estimado
podemos mantener la Calma
sí era algo esperado como decía Daniel
es decir ninguna pandemia se va a
desaparecer En tan poco tiempo de hecho
pues si miramos la historia solamente
hemos erradicado la viruela y tardamos
casi 200 años en el plan de vacunación
Así que no vamos a
a vencer en solamente dos años una
pandemia ahora bien tratar de llegar al
punto de cero que pretende china
eso pues ni siquiera es una utopía eso
siempre llanamente no es Sensato eso no
es cierto no es posible al menos para
los que estamos vivos en este momento en
el planeta
a ninguno de nosotros nos va a tocar ver
el Coby cero Entonces yo creo que el
tema de China responde más a una
situación de índole político que a una
de índole sanitario por tanto tomarlo
como referente en realidad no creo que
lo más adecuado igual como decía Daniel
esto es esperado en las temporadas de
invierno que se dan principalmente en el
hemisferio norte o en ciudades tan frías
como puede ser Bogotá es decir en
ciudades con determinada altitud donde
pues la baja de temperatura sobre todo
en la época de la niña que estamos
sufriendo en Colombia pues hace que
bajen las temperaturas de forma
importante ahora viene que aclarar Esto
no es que el invierno sí trae
infecciones respiratorias ella no vienen
ni con la nieve ni con la lluvia no lo
único que sucede es que la ventilación
en los sitios cerrados se vuelve de mala
calidad Pues porque están cubiertos
precisamente porque está haciendo mucho
frío entonces es por eso que sea el
aumento de todas las infecciones
respiratorias en temporadas de invierno
Jaime continúo con usted para hacer la
ronda la inversa y preguntarle a lo
largo de estos tres años el mundo poco a
poco fue levantando las restricciones
eliminando el uso de la mascarilla o el
distanciamiento social o el lavado de
manos que eran
las tres reglas de oro para evitar tener
el virus a raya digámoslo así pero china
se mantiene con esta política de cero
covid que usted dice responde más a un
índole político desde su perspectiva
pero
este repunte de casos de ahora estos
casos que también se están reportando en
algunos en algunas regiones de China que
han llevado a nuevos confinamientos
sectorizados nos hace pensar que tal vez
los chinos estaban en en lo correcto en
mantener las restricciones que debimos
haber sido un poco más juiciosos a lo
largo de estos tres años y hacer y haber
mantenido esas restricciones y no haber
abierto la economía de haber abierto la
sociedad tan rápidamente que balance
hace usted
en lo personal creo que la posición de
China no es la correcta seguir
manteniendo las economías cerradas pues
la crisis económica que está empezando a
sufrir el mundo y que va a sufrir en
2023 comenzó precisamente con las
restricciones que hubo lo que pasa es
que luego hubo otras cosas el tema de la
crisis de los contenedores la inflación
de Rusia Ucrania con la crisis
energética entonces claro todo esto es
una Tormenta perfecta para la crisis
económica 2023 Entonces no no creo que
haya sido incorrecto No creo que Por así
decirlo occidente se haya equivocado
insisto ahí hay un tema político
importante de control de la población
que se observa incluso Pues con un gran
irrespeto los Derechos Humanos que hay
en China Claro
que ellos también tienen temporada
invernal además ellos hacen mucha mayor
búsqueda activa que cualquier otro país
en el mundo yo me Cuánto es qué tal si
hiciéramos la misma búsqueda activa de
influenza es bastante probable que
encontremos más influencia que Kobe 19 y
nadie se está jalando los cabellos por
el aumento de la influenza Cuando
tenemos programas Hace cuánto la OMS
está diciendo hay que vacunarse
anualmente Cuántos países Cuántos
sistemas de salud asumen el costo de esa
vacuna contra influenza que está
recomendada por la OMS desde hace muchos
años esas son preguntas que tienen
bastante impacto posiblemente mucho
mayor que el que tendría covid ahora y
que pone en cuestionamiento los
programas de vacunación de muchos países
que dejan de lado de pronto el tema de
la influenza para poderse concentrar en
otras vacunas más importantes Daniel
retomó la comunicación con usted y le
pregunto desde su perspectiva esta
política china del cero covid le parece
que dio un buen resultado y que el
manejo que le ha dado el resto del mundo
y no quiero decir solamente porque
también muchos países asiáticos han
seguido la misma tendencia de ir
abriendo poco a poco de forma escalonada
como lo vimos en estos tres años Fue una
buena idea qué balance hace usted
Mire yo creo que es muy importante hacer
un balance correcto y adecuadamente
contextualizado desde mi punto de vista
el mundo entero ha sido como dicen
ustedes en Colombia poco juicioso con
respecto a retirar las medidas de
protección y las medidas restrictivas
hemos ido demasiado por libre para
reducir el uso de la mascarilla permitir
las aglomeraciones no vacunar
suficientemente reducir el número de de
pruebas diagnósticas y eso es un error
eso no es una política acertada esta
llamada gripalización de la cobi 19 Por
eso tenemos seiscientos cuarenta y cinco
millones de casos y por eso tenemos seis
punto seis millones de muertes en el
mundo que es más que lo que produce una
conflagración mundial pero tomemos en
cuenta que el mundo ha ido muy lento en
vacunar solo el sesenta y ocho por
ciento de la población ha recibido
cuando menos una dosis en el mundo
tenemos 30 desprotegido y en los países
de bajos ingresos solo el veinticuatro
punto cinco por ciento ha recibido
cuando menos una dosis de vacunación es
decir tiene tres cuartas partes de su
población desprotegida cuando china
ASUME una política como la de covid Cero
y no es solo china fueron muchos países
en Oriente Corea fue Japón pues Singapur
fue Australia fue Nueva Zelanda desde mi
punto de vista tomó una decisión
acertada que fue equivocada en occidente
de pensar en occidente que se podía
dejar el virus a su libre circulación y
que la inmunidad que se iba a generar de
modo natural iba a generar una inmunidad
de grupo bueno Esto han sido falacias
demostradas ni hay inmunidad de grupo
con covid que muta tanto y en donde la
vacuna no es efectiva por tanto tiempo
ni se puede lograr con una circulación
libre del virus una circulación benigna
ha habido un número considerable muertes
que pudieron haber sido evitado Entonces
yo creo que que china hizo lo correcto
en su momento al tomar medidas
draconianas para evitar el colapso
asistencial que podría suponer millones
de ocupaciones hospitalarias en un país
tan poblado y para evitar un número muy
elevado de función ahora lo que hay que
tomar en cuenta es que no se puede
sostener por tres años medidas
draconianas sin tener una adecuada
pedagogía social y diálogo con la
población no es un tema de abrir o
cerrar la economía yo creo que donde no
hemos entendido las cosas es en que lo
ideal es que tengamos el menos número de
contagios posibles porque el covid es
Severo mata colapsa la asistencia
sanitaria y produce covid
Daniel Entonces en este momento con el
panorama que tenemos en este momento que
hay aumento de casos en diferentes
países de América Latina todavía no son
cantidades de casos que lleven a
decretar algún tipo de emergencia alerta
simplemente las autoridades están
haciendo seguimientos es momento
Entonces de hacer intensiva la
vacunación o es momento de
restablecer algunas restricciones
básicas Como por ejemplo el uso de la
mascarilla el distanciamiento del lavado
de manos no lleguemos a un escenario de
un confinamiento estricto y del cierre
total de algunos de los países Vámonos
por lo menos con esa primera fase claro
Sí yo yo creo que no debemos de pensar
que tenemos que llegar al a la conducta
extrema del confinamiento como hubo que
hacerlo Al principio de la pandemia en
países de América Latina o de Europa y
fue importante para evitar muertes en
estos momentos hay que tomar una acción
muy decisiva de intensificar vacunación
con la cuarta dosis de refuerzo con la
vacuna bivalente que va muy lento en un
país como España que lo ha tomado como
una prioridad incluso solo se ha logrado
vacunar al cuarenta y cinco por ciento
de la población mayor de 60 años y al
68% de la mayor de 80 años hay que ir
mucho más rápido para antes de las
navidades completar una cobertura
vacunal plena con esta cuarta dosis de
refuerzo pero muchos países de América
Latina ni se la han planteado no está
llegando esta vacuna bivalente y eso me
parece que es un error estratégico desde
un punto de vista de salud pública hay
que vacunar periódicamente ya lo dijo
Anthony fauci el asesor de la Casa
Blanca este es una vacuna que tendrá que
hacerse anualmente porque la vacuna
decae en eficacia de protección
inmunitaria el virus muta cambia
Entonces tenemos que tomar en cuenta
este equilibrio precario y hay que
volver a medidas como la mascarilla en
interiores o en aglomeraciones en donde
tenemos más de contagio y Jaime Cuál es
su opinión entonces reforzar la
vacunación o tomar medidas de
restricciones básicas por lo menos
mientras Pasa este nuevo no quiero
decirle pico porque la cantidad de casos
no es tan representativa como para
llamarle un pico pero tal vez sí una ola
en Perú se le ha llamado una ola de
contagio
es la mayor importancia en América
Latina no hemos adquirido vacunas
bivalentes Yo creo que ni siquiera saben
que es el tema ambivalente Entonces como
para que aclaremos en América Latina la
vacuna original era contra la variante
original y esa es la única que se está
aplicando en América Latina las vacunas
los laboratorios que desarrollaron
vacunas de ADN tanto pfizer como moderna
desarrollaron una segunda vacuna contra
la variante omicron Y esto es muy
importante porque todas estas
variantes que estamos observando ahora
todas son de o micro Y no estamos
vacunando con la vacuna bivalente que es
la que fue diseñada para o micro
Entonces
si seguimos aplicando una vacuna para
una variante que no está circulando
es un esfuerzo descomunal que no tiene
ningún sentido eso se quejó Daniel es
fundamental si en Latinoamérica no
compra la vacuna que sí es que es la
bivalente que es la que protege contra
omicron ese esfuerzo no valdrá la pena
una vez la compre y Esperemos que así
sea entonces hay que empezar a buscar
otras estrategias es decir Buscar activa
de los pacientes que no se han vacunado
Si la gente no se va a ir a vacunar el
sistema de información el sistema de
salud tiene la información de dónde
están ubicados sobre todo los de mayor
riesgo es decir mayores de 65 años
buscarlos ahora bien miremos Quiénes
están falleciendo en Colombia estamos
reportando en promedio dos muertes
diarias
podrían ser 60 muertes mensuales esta
población es población que usualmente
tiene inmunodeficiencias primarias y
secundarias ya no es población general
Por así decirlo Entonces ya tendríamos
que buscar otras estrategias ya hay
anticuerpos monoclonales predisposición
para estas poblaciones específicas ya no
es algo luminoso Pero además poblaciones
específicas que no van a desarrollar
inmunidad ni siquiera con la equivalente
ahora también fíjese el tema de Joe
biden el dos o tres veces un hombre que
es casi octogenario y ahí está como si
nada tuvo acceso a otros medicamento que
no estamos en en Latinoamérica que no lo
tenemos en Latinoamérica entonces que si
lo tienen en Europa hay un medicamento
que cuando las personas están infectadas
y se da oportunamente disminuye el
riesgo de desarrollar complicaciones
entonces antes de empezar a decirle a la
gente antes de que los gobiernos le
digan a la gente Póngase mascarilla o
hagan restricciones los gobiernos
deberían empezar a pensar hombre Y yo
por qué no compro la vacuna bivalente
porque no voy la aplico hasta el hogar
porque no compro porque no compro pass
load eso son cosas que llegaría a decir
es muy fácil decir la gente Póngase
mascarilla y haga restricción los
gobiernos centrales También tienen una
obligación y es por ahí por donde
empieza en realidad claro y deben de
actuar de forma responsable Es mejor
prevenir con las vacunas que tener que
hacer cierres que genera un efecto de
bola de nieve a nivel económico a nivel
social bastante importante a lo largo de
estos tres años
Jaime Le perdimos un poco el rastro a el
virus del Kobe 19 cada tanto tiempo
reportábamos la aparición de una
variante de una que aparecía en África
la otra aparecía en Asia la otra parecía
en Europa y en los últimos años hemos
perdido un poco el rastro al virus cómo
se está comportando el virus del Kobe 19
hoy en día Cuál es la variante que está
haciendo predominante y esta que
diferencia tiene con respecto a las
otras
bueno como variante la variante es
omicron lo que hay son linajes entonces
o micro tiene una serie de linajes Yo
calculo que puede haber una docena de
linajes en este momento lo que pasa es
que de esos 12 linajes en cada país va a
haber una prevalencia diferente de esos
linajes es cada país va a tener ver unos
diferentes que los otros eso va a seguir
sucediendo porque eso es lo que hace un
virus es tratar de buscar cómo
reproducirse para poder infectar la
razón de un virus es infectar porque si
uno no va a existir entonces van a
mantenerse esto linajes ahora bien el
sitio aparición o desaparición ya en
realidad recordemos que la OMS
sugirió y estableció que llamáramos las
variantes por letras del alfabeto griego
precisamente para evitar
estigmatizaciones de donde apareció la
nueva variante entonces en parte no
sabemos dónde aparecieron estos linajes
con esta manejo de las de las letras del
alfabeto griego evitamos este tipo de
estigmatizaciones pero lo que claro es
que hay más o menos aproximadamente una
docena de linajes en todo el mundo pero
en cada país va a cambiar la proporción
de linaje que es dominando en cada uno
Daniel paso a preguntarle con Jaime
hablábamos del virus Pero entonces ahora
hablemos de las vacunas cómo está el
desarrollo de las vacunas ya ahí me
explicaba un poco esta vacuna necesaria
bivalente que es la que deberíamos
aplicarnos ahora como cuarta dosis para
hacer frente a la situación en la que
estamos ahora qué más ha desarrollado o
qué más ha encontrado la industria
farmacéutica para hacer frente al Kobe
19 que como ustedes ya lo han dicho Esto
va a perdurar Esto va a seguir y es algo
a lo que nos tenemos que acostumbrar
yo creo que lo primero es entender que
que no hay un equilibrio
único estático sino que esta es una
situación muy dinámica surgen nuevas
variantes tenemos que saber si nuestras
vacunas son eficaces contra las nuevas
variantes o linajes o sub linajes que se
vayan presentando y en esa medida
ajustar el tipo de vacuna que se utiliza
a la situación epidemiológica en
términos de los virus presentes entonces
en estos momentos pues tiene todo el
sentido del mundo y yo sigo insistiendo
yo acabo de volver de México y estoy en
España en estos momentos me sorprendió
notablemente el que no se esté aplicando
la vacuna bivalente para una dosis de
refuerzo yo me he puesto en un brazo la
de influenza y en otro la cuarta dosis
de refuerzo hace dos meses con la
bivalente en España y sigo usando
mascarilla en interiores y en exteriores
aglomerados yo Considero que hay que
entender esta esta forma de equilibrio
para manejar la pandemia y avanzar en el
uso adecuado de la vacuna adecuada Ahora
hay también anticuerpos monoclonales
como lo lo mencionaba Jaime hace un
momento
el pac lo vi por ejemplo que en Europa
sí se puede conseguir Está autorizado se
puede utilizar para reducir la severidad
de quien ya fue infectado no hay en
estos momentos Eso sí ni una sola
solución mágica de vacuna esterilizante
que impida el contagio me impiden o
reducen el riesgo de morir o el riesgo
de hospitalización pero hasta ahí llegan
y tampoco hay un medicamento que sea la
curación total y plena son atenuantes de
posibles casos severos especialmente en
poblaciones más vulnerables Por eso
tenemos que lograr un equilibrio entre
la protección con medios farmacológicos
y las medidas no farmacológicas que
tiene que ver con reducir el riesgo de
contagio
Volver al lavado de manos Volver al uso
de la mascarilla
en temporadas otoño invernales y no ver
esto como una pérdida de libertad sino
como una necesidad de protegernos y de
proteger a los demás claro y lo que
usted dicen hay que recalcarlo es que la
pandemia no ha terminado el covid sigue
presente Entonces tenemos que seguir
haciéndole frente a este virus que
continúa con nosotros
Daniel es importante Resaltar lo que
significó para la humanidad esta
pandemia Kobe 19 lo que vino a
enseñarnos como sociedad como economías
como países Naciones para hacer frente a
la situación en estos tres años qué
balance hace usted de esta pandemia de
Kobe 19 en avances médicos o en avance
de tipo social Qué lección nos deja esto
para replicarlo Si volvemos a tener una
situación similar
la pandemia de Coby nos ha dejado muchas
lecciones pero no todas ellas las hemos
aprendido ni las hemos internalizado yo
creo que lamentablemente no estamos
haciendo lo necesario para invertir en
acciones de salud pública preparativos
pandémicos y planes de contingencia como
para estar preparado para nuevas
pandemias en el mundo no hemos puesto en
apunte de de funcionamiento adecuado los
mecanismos internacionales del
reglamento sanitario internacional
estamos discutiendo el sexo de Los
Ángeles con respecto a la idea de un
tratado pandémico y nos movemos muy
lentamente con los mecanismos como el
covax o el acelerator para garantizar
vacuna o garantizar medicamentos o
pruebas diagnósticas a los países más
desfavorecidos no hemos hecho lo
necesario en términos de entender que
hay necesidad de una peda social más
amplia más acabada en donde se trabaje
con la población para reducir los
riesgos y se pueda explicar el Por qué
se toman ciertas ciertas conductas
pandémicas hay evidentemente muchas
cosas que hemos aprendido el desarrollo
de las vacunas ha sido un gran logro en
poco tiempo pero no estamos desde mi
punto de vista haciendo lo necesario
para aprender las lecciones que la
pandemia nos deja Para futuras pandemias
y para mejorar la seguridad sanitaria
mundial Quiero preguntarle a Jaime en su
punto de vista sobre estas lecciones que
nos deja Qué opina usted
nuevamente estoy de acuerdo con Daniel
de todo lo que haya para aprender no
aprendimos nada seamos honestos es decir
que que nos quedó lo mismo que decía
Daniel nos quedó bien que la ciencia
respondió
jamás habíamos pensado que se iba a
desarrollar una buena vacuna en tan poco
tiempo
eso de alguna forma va a impulsar otras
líneas para el desarrollo de vacunas en
otras enfermedades yo creo que está ahí
Es decir fíjese que por ejemplo cuando
empezó la pandemia entonces aparecían
fotos en todas partes del mundo de cómo
la naturaleza estaba otra vez los
animales saliendo al aire libre y todo
porque todos estábamos guardados pero
también habló pues no es que terminó
pero se quitaron las restricciones y
otra vez a contaminar como si nada
hubiera pasado Así es sencillo
usted como periodista sabe Mucho mejor
que nosotros lo que fue el tema de
desinformación eso me dejó a mí
impactado ver cualquier cantidad de
líderes políticos
Daniel es de México y sabe del
presidente para abajo lo que hubo
desinformación allá
deportistas religiosos y youtubers el
nivel de desinformación que Se generó es
impresionante y la gente a pesar de ver
tanta mentira tanta cosa que se dijo
sigue creyendo en eso recuerde que se
hablaba del cloro todas las cosas que
sellaron de tantos medicamentos que me
sirvieron para nada entonces a pesar de
que la ciencia demostró que si
funcionaba
la gente sigue escuchando los mensajes
incorrectos la gente escucha lo que
quiere escuchar y eso no ha cambiado no
lo va a cambiar la pandemia eso es un
tema cultural que cada sociedad debe
darle un impulso importante a la ciencia
e incluso a los difusores de ciencia por
ejemplo periodistas que se se vuelvan
exclusivos para difundir la ciencia que
haya apoyo para eso yo hablaba con unos
decanos de medicina y les decía vea una
de las cosas que me intereste entristece
es ver como la mayor parte de los
médicos desconocen tanto tanto de
epidemiología hablamos mal a todos los
médicos hablamos de cardiología todos
Hablamos de Medicina interna y al
momento de hablar de epidemiología los
conceptos más básicos se desconocen en
las facultades de Medicina la
epidemiología era casi que un relleno en
el pensum y hoy se dieron cuenta que es
necesario pero a pesar de eso yo no he
visto la primera Facultad de Medicina
que haga un cambio importante en el
pensum para ver lo importante que es la
epidemiología y la salud pública en la
toma de decisiones solo por citar Jaime
Daniel algunos de los comentarios que
hicieron algunos jefes de estado en
América Latina recordemos no va a decir
nombre uno que mostraba una estampita de
no sé si era religioso de algo
tradicional de su país que le decía
detente al virus y otro que decía que
era simplemente una gripita y ya vemos
que deja Casi 6 millones de fallecidos
a lo largo de estos tres años en Jaime
continuo con usted para preguntarle por
un punto muy importante y es que la
pandemia comenzó empezaron estos casos
en buján en China se convirtió en una
gran catástrofe a nivel económico para
la mayoría de los países Pero sigue
siendo un misterio entender De dónde
viene entender dónde se originó este
virus en China un accidente de
laboratorio Si fue por un proceso de
evolución normal de un de un virus ya
existente si fue una composición de
diferentes factores que se sabe del
origen del covid tres años después de
haber empezado la pandemia
Santiago en realidad real yo aparte de
epidemiólogo economista de la salud y en
economía hay unos principios en los
cuales hay ciertas cosas hacia atrás que
no van a cambiar lo que viene hacia
adelante Entonces si fue o no empujada
Si fue un murciélago si fue o no un
armadillo en realidad qué podría qué
tanto podría impactar hacia lo que viene
no creo que mucho además Si volvemos al
tema que la MS dijo hey no vamos a
estigmatizar
pues terminar señalando que fue que fue
china Ahí va a haber una estigmatización
es un hecho que este es un momento
políticamente complicado para el mundo
Así que saliera a decir que occidente
vaya diga china fue el culpable eso
podría generar un cambio en la balanza
de China hacia el apoyo a Rusia en
invasión a Ucrania y cuando están
empezando el infierno en Europa que es
lo que menos necesitan entonces
en realidad ya lo que haya de aquí para
adelante ya eso es historia
será importante para la historia A mí me
encanta la historia pero ya es algo de
historia ya que eso nos vaya a afectar
de alguna forma la toma de decisiones
claro de aquí en adelante no no creo que
haya un valor agregado importante
Daniel le pregunto por el escenario
actual en el que estamos estamos
haciendo frente en cierta forma al
calentamiento climático hay muchas
teorías en torno a a este calentamiento
de nuestro planeta como uno de los
factores que ha provocado la aparición
de este virus y de este y de otros más
que a raíz de que se está
descongelando el permafrost en las zonas
donde habitualmente las capas interiores
del suelo estaban congeladas eso está
liberando algunos virus el escenario
actual de este calentamiento global Las
Guerras actuales la deficiencia
económica que están presentando algunos
países que les obliga a reducir
inversiones En programas de salud para
poder hacer frente a otros temas
económicos esto Cómo se está volviendo
digamos en un escenario de una Tormenta
perfecta para para hacer frente a una
pandemia a gran escala más adelante esto
afectará claro
por supuesto yo yo creo que son varias
las dimensiones que hay que tomar en
cuenta de estos fenómenos que estamos
viviendo primero Sin lugar a dudas hay
un impacto sobre la salud del cambio
climático y del calentamiento global en
términos de surgimiento de enfermedades
infecciosas pero también en términos de
afectación por otro tipo de patologías
que se ven
aceleradas por el cambio climático
muchas enfermedades transmitidas por
vectores han tenido recrudecimientos en
razón del cambio climático los fenómenos
del niño de la niña asociados al aumento
de temperaturas han determinado nuevas
densidades de mosquitos que transmiten
enfermedades infecciosas importantes el
incremento de la malaria de zika de
chiquinguña de dengue por ejemplo
además de lo que supone la afectación de
en términos de trastornos respiratorios
y de enfermedades crónicas pero a ver yo
creo que lo que tenemos que aprender de
todo esto es primero que tenemos que
tener mucho cuidado con el Salto de
nuevos patógenos de especies animales a
especies humanas no es solo covid ya
todas las otras infecciones por por
coronavirus el sars el mers sabemos que
fueron saltos de especies animales de la
civeta al hombre del dromedario al
hombre acá muy probablemente el
murciélago pangolín a el hombre pero
también lo ha sido el ébola y lo fue y
lo fue en su momento el surgimiento del
virus del VIH sida Entonces yo creo que
esto refuerza la noción de que tenemos
que tener una visión más integrada de
Salud Ambiental salud humana y salud
animal la llamada salud única One Health
en inglés en donde tengamos
de salud pública que eviten el que este
este esta evolución que está teniendo la
transformación de la naturaleza tan
criminal que estamos haciendo
redunde en problemas que se traduzcan
posteriormente en pandemias o en
afectaciones a las personas pero no
descartemos que tenemos también
conflicto crisis energética y crisis
económica y esta combinación es la
Tormenta perfecta como tú decías y son
de alguna manera Jinetes del Apocalipsis
que nos golpean de manera muy
determinada me queda un par de minutos
para finalizar el programa Daniel Jaime
me parece importante hacer conclusiones
y también hacer los llamados pertinentes
a la a la sociedad France 24 tiene
difusión en toda América Latina no con
el ánimo de alarmar sino de reiterarle a
la a la a la comunidad y a los
televidentes los cuidados que tienen que
tener a partir de este momento hacer
llamados tempranos
importante para prevenir y Cuáles pueden
ser las recomendaciones simplemente para
evitar que esto siga avanzando y
simplemente interiorizar este tipo de
normas en nuestra cotidianidad
mantenerlas para prevenir el contagio
del Coby 19 porque como ustedes dicen
las vacunas previenen que los síntomas
sean muy fuertes pero no previene que
uno no se contagia y el virus sigue ahí
en el día a día en nuestro entorno
comienzo entonces con Jaime para esta
conclusión final del programa adelante
Jaime
yo haría el llamado primero a los
gobiernos centrales que no nos dejen
abandonados que no dejen toda la carga
sobre la población es decir deben traer
vacunas bivalentes a latinoamérica deben
aplicarme los medicamentos que ya
hablamos paslovir deben traer eucer a
latinoamérica que no los tenemos
disponibles Entonces primero comenzar
por eso al tiempo que la población
general pues tenga los cuidados que se
deben tener para el manejo respiratoria
y soy muy existente cuando las personas
estén sintomáticas por favor adíslense
autoadirlese porque es que a veces
tenemos síntomas leves de resfriado y
creemos que eso no es problema y vamos a
trabajar así no debemos aislarnos porque
como ya dijimos en temporadas frías los
sitios cerrados pues van a estar mal
ventilados y aumentamos el riesgo de
contagiar seamos tengamos empatía y
evitemos contagiar a los demás cuando
estemos infectados insisto el llamado a
los gobiernos centrales para que tengan
disponibilidad de las tecnologías que sí
son para toda la región y Daniel su
conclusión para el cierre del programa
adelante Sí además de coincidir con lo
que ella dijo Jaime yo diría es muy
importante transmitir a los gobiernos a
las autoridades sanitarias a la
población la noción de que la pandemia
no ha terminado que no podemos bajar la
guardia Qué hay que invertir en planes
pandémicos en infraestructura de salud
pública en medidas que tengan que ver
con ampliar la cobertura de vacunación
con las vacunas útiles como la vacuna
bivalente y con la necesidad de realizar
pruebas diagnósticas en mayor medida y
de tener los sistemas de vigilancia
epidemiológica y rastreo a punto de
manera que funcionen para detectar el
problema Yo creo que hay que reforzar
también la noción de que no debemos
abandonar las medidas de protección como
es el uso de la mascarilla como es el
lavado de manos como es la para evitar
contagios Y insistiría como dijo Jaime
en que la gente que está con
sintomatología se aliste no podemos
pensar en que esto no tiene una
severidad si se transmite así que bueno
Yo creo que es volver algunos mensajes
antiguos pero importantes sí Daniel
Jaime pues les agradezco mucho por este
análisis por estas alertas aclararnos
también mucho del panorama que estamos
viendo actualmente en América Latina les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Lina Guzmán
sigan con France 24
[Música]